stéphane hudon et le proche aidant de sa
mère de 92 ans atteintes d'alzheimer
depuis dix ans mon père décédé en 2006
ma mère a commencé à avoir des petits
troubles de mémoire assez fréquent et ma
soeur me suis avait dit ça va prendre
quelques avant impôts en reste avec elle
grâce au programme chèques emplois
services du ministère de la santé et des
services sociaux olivette chabot peut
demeurer dans sa résidence
le gouvernement lui accorde 30 heures de
soins à domicile par semaine qui lui
sont dispensés par une travailleuse
provenant du privé l'état lui alloue 12
et 50 l'heure et s'occupe de toutes les
déductions fiscales relié à son salaire
mamerow rien à faire à ce clip de rien
apport de trouver une ressource en 2017
une aidante à domicile se plaint que
certains avantages sociaux ne lui ont
pas été versée selon la loi sur les
normes du travail
la commission des normes de l'équité de
la santé et de la sécurité du travail et
responsable de l'application de la loi
poursuit olivier chabot on identifie
comme employeur de son un dante bonfim
est une usagère elle reçoit des services
à peut pas être l'employant la ressource
il
on n'a jamais expliqué à moi ou à ma
mère qu'à partir du moment où aux
bénéficiaires du programme chaque impro
services ont donné des employeurs la
façon que le programme chèques emploi
services et structures et fait en sorte
que la plupart des attributs de
l'employeur qui recrutent qui encadrent
au quotidien seront assumés par le ou la
bénéficiaire selon m fecteau les onze
mille bénéficiaires du programme n'ont
pas le choix d'accepter ce rôle si les
personnes veulent bénéficier des
services qui sont proposés par ce
programme là c'est un carcan dans lequel
ils n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
souscrire et c'est un peu le pied à edge
finalement de ce programme la personne
au gouvernement n'a accepté d'en
discuter à la caméra depuis plus de
vingt ans des organismes représentant
les bénéficiaires de ce programme
demande de le modifier pour éviter les
recours judiciaires contre eux encore
aujourd'hui rien n'a changé ici nancy
desjardins radio canada montréal